if an investigation were about to end
would the guy running the investigation
hire even more prosecutors you tell me
Donald Trump has been telling us for a
long time now that we're almost at the
end of this thing the Moller
investigation is just about to end we
heard last year that it would be over by
Thanksgiving 2017 when it didn't end we
were told it would be over by New Year's
Day January 1 2018
that didn't happen throughout early 2018
and even over the last month or so we've
been told time and time again that it's
it's almost over we're really almost at
the end here and we learned over the
weekend that special counsel robert
muller has hired even more prosecutors
to work the investigation prosecutors as
the name implies prosecute you hire them
if you want them to partake in
prosecution and prosecution related
activities and the report is that Robert
Muller is going to be expanding that
team and potentially even stepping away
from some of the casework I've said it
before and I'm going to remind you if
the investigation ended today the
prosecution of the cases we already have
could take years if we have another six
to 12 months of investigation and
further indictments we are looking at
this stretching into Donald Trump's
second term for sure or potentially even
into well depending on whether Trump
wins or loses the next president's first
term so far we have 20 indictments and
five guilty pleas at the end of the day
I don't pretend to know what will happen
I get emails from people Pat who say
David why are you so sure that XYZ is
going to go down or that Trump's inner
circle is going to end up in prison I've
never said anything like that I don't
know what's ultimately going to happen
what I do know is that number one
there's no evidence or indication that
this investigation is almost over that's
number one number two we know that
Watergate took years that means that
this may take years if this is bigger
than Watergate
it could take significantly longer than
Watergate and this gets us right back to
don't beat me up Pat but I've got to
mention it this gets us right back to
voting
in 2018 and 2020 I was thinking over the
weekend why might someone want to vote
in November well as I mentioned earlier
don't hurt me I know I mentioned this
midterm turnout is often low that means
your vote if you choose to vote matters
more House and Senate control is key to
stopping the Trump agenda taking over
the House and Senate in 2018 better
positions you to win in 2020 but related
to the Muller investigation Muller can
say whatever he wants he can issue
whatever findings he wants to issue
Republicans are not going to act on
Mulder's findings Muller has been
smeared and discredited and while it's
bogus it works with the right it works
with Republicans and that is going to
provide cover for Republicans when
Moeller finally tells us whatever it is
that he found Republicans will say these
are political reports we can't act on
what Muller found because Muller is
compromised which is why Democrats must
take over the House and Senate so that
they will act on whatever Moeller's
findings are yeah and it's also becoming
increasingly clear that a sitting
president cannot be indicted
so if Trump is going to face any
criminal repercussions for what he may
have done we have to come through
impeachment after yeah yeah and that's
not gonna happen if Democrats don't have
control of the House or Senate no
question about it no question about it
so whatever you care about if it's
seeing consequences to the molar
investigation or seeing the tariffs that
are destroying farmers who by the way
are mostly still supporting Trump even
though Trump is hurting them it's
stunning cognitive dissonance that's
going on whatever is important to you it
all leads back to voting in November
what it what's the date I should so I
would be able to say November 6th is it
the 6th don't hold me to that yeah I
don't know what the in the first week of
November of 2018 quick break we will be
back after this discuss this or any
stories of interest from today's show on
the david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD i.t today's
program made possible in part by zip
recruiter hiring used to be very
difficult multiple job sites stacks
resumes a confusing review process but
zip recruiter makes hiring much easier
you only have to go to one place to get
it done it's zip recruiter dot-com slash
Pakman zip recruiter sends your job to
over a hundred of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter will scan thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job as the applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one spotlights
the top candidates so you don't miss a
great match and zip recruiter is so
effective that 80% of employers get a
quality candidate through the site
within the first day
zip recruiter is the highest rated
hiring site in the US and our viewers
and listeners can try zip recruiter for
free at the exclusive web site zip
recruiter dot-com / Pakman zip recruiter
dot-com /pa KMA n try it free as a David
Pakman show viewer or listener zip
recruiter dot-com / Pakman